foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
I could be dying of thirst
dehydrated to the point where I was
gonna Keel over and I would not trust
bottle
of trump water would you I wouldn't
him
okay so we're gonna talk about this Ohio
derailment again
that's that's what everyone wants to
talk about is the Ohio one because there
was toxics chemical spilled in this uh
town where the majority of people voted
for republicans and continued to vote
for Republicans they will continue to
vote for Republicans a lot of people
gave me when this first happened
and I said hey this is ohioan's fault
foreign
this derailment that they're bitching
about in their town and they're
complaining about all of a sudden JD
Vance is all of a sudden
environmentalist did you notice that
holy ten days after he found out
that holy oh my God you know what I
can I can politicize this issue I'm
going to become an environmentalist it's
amazing how they become environmentalist
overnight didn't it
when when there's a little bit of
chemicals in a creek somewhere
and drinking water may be compromised oh
forget Detroit that lead in the
water it's in a black community ah
that the environment climate
change all that let him drink
the lead let him
but when there's a little bit of
chemical in a creek somewhere oh my god
listen the reason why Pete Buddha judge
and that's the craziest part to me is
they're saying oh my god look how long
it took Pete boot a judge to get there
he's there the day after Trump was there
you stupid
not to mention the EPA was there on the
ground immediately immediately and
Governor dewine told them to off
Joe Biden offered federal assistance he
told them to off
stop voting for Republicans this is not
a Democrat issue this is not a policy
issue this is not a regulation issue
this is Republicans don't give a
about you issue we've been talking about
it for a long time
oh they're going to go on about mayor
Pete oh there's a video of him out there
I don't know it looks like he's having a
conversation as he's walking with a town
official as reporters are shouting
questions to him and he doesn't answer
any of the reporters questions because
he's paying attention
he didn't go he didn't go with a bunch
of Mayor Pete hats and mayor Pete water
and go sign autographs and throw water
at people and then and then go to
McDonald's and sign Trump hats
he didn't do that mayor Pete isn't doing
that he's working
because he's a serious person
a lot of people are pointing out the
Trump water thing uh
that oh Trump water was bankrupt like 10
years ago and that this water is 13
years old of course again I'm making
jokes about it that I wouldn't trust
drinking that
I wouldn't I wouldn't I wouldn't
even put a hat on of his that's why I'm
wearing my red hat today
this is a real red hat and I want to
make Red Hats wearable again
toxic sludge ass from
Mar-A-Lago
grifting his supporters
grifting his supporters to fly all the
way
to East Palestine
Ohio where this train wreck is
that he caused
I'm going to show you a video today of a
railroad track in Ohio this video is
kind of going viral around the internet
I don't think people really quite
understand at railways
they they don't understand especially
the freight Railways right even in the
video a lot of people comment like oh my
God can you imagine a passenger train on
this rail there's not passenger chains
on that rail
there's not because there's regulations
for passenger cars on those types of
rails it's called regulation we do that
so we protect ourselves from
corporations
like Norfolk Southern
and everyone wants to blame it on them
obviously obviously it's their toxic
spill
but it's because we did not hold them
accountable we allowed Ohioans and
everyone else to be complacent to
vote based on affiliation and
have really shitty policy makers
that are bought and paid for by the
lobby for Norfolk Southern to deregulate
the industry to not have braking systems
on rail cars
that are carrying toxic chemicals
because climate change is real that'll
show those live tards
if we
as the pro-democracy Coalition do not
pluck our head out of our ass and stop
pointing the fingers at ourselves
oh it did well God damn Joe Biden mayor
Pete oh well oh my God the Democrats
up Joe Biden had planned for
weeks and weeks and weeks before the
train wreck and it's not the only train
wreck folks this is not the only
train wreck where there's chemicals
leaking into the Earth
it's not the only one
it just so happens that this one is in a
very heavy Trump area
oh my God
I can't believe Joe Biden went to
Ukraine when he could have went to Ohio
listen if Joe Biden went to every
train wreck in this country
that's all he would be doing you stupid
that's all he would be doing
because we can't get our we can't
we can't even make sure that a
weapon of War doesn't get into an
elementary school and Slaughter dozens
of children
we can't even do that for
ourselves you think you think you think
that we could just fix the railroad
system ah just like that oh
corporate greed we can we can lock it
down get the out of here with that
nonsense
you can't do it if you keep voting in
people who don't give a about you
so stop voting Republican and I'm sick
and tired of hearing the excuse oh
they're gerrymander oh Ohio's Gary
Vander Tony we're Democrats and we work
here in Ohio and it's gerrymandered the
governor is Republican you can't
gerrymander a republican District dummy
the United States Senator JD Vance on
the ground with Trump chucking it up oh
yeah you guys have a great time is what
they said oh yeah have a great time I
hope you guys hope you guys have a great
time cleaning up this mess that
Republicans caused
JD Vance's United States Senate District
isn't gerrymandered you dumb bastards
it's not
stop making excuses
stop stop self-suppressing our vote stop
self-suppressing our outrage
stop it
you want to make something for this
country you want to make something for
your kids you want something for the
Next Generation to be able to
have safe railroad cars safe freight
trains
do something
stop making excuses fight
acting like this Trump trump this trip
of Trumps is somehow gonna catapult him
to the presidency the media is a bunch
of dumb and anyone out
there complaining about this is a bunch
of dumb all you gotta do
is listen watch 30 seconds of tape of
this buffoon going to Ohio and you can
mock the out of him and know that
he did no serious work at all none not a
goddamn bit decoding Fox News the
Twitter account that I like to follow
she did a marvelous job of breaking down
his speech of how much he actually
talked about the people of East
Palestine like two minutes
he don't give a about you you
redneck trust me I is one
and I knows it
and then dance you know oh he he post a
video and I I I tweeted it
because they think it's a burn on Biden
that Trump shows up in this town and he
starts he starts signing autographs for
a crowd of tens of people
who if those dumb bastards knew the
truth they wouldn't let him
within a hundred miles of that
town but they don't know the truth
because they don't want to know the
truth
they don't want to know the truth folks
the truth does not fit their narrative
it doesn't it won't it never will
that's why they love the delusion of Fox
News speaking of delusion of Fox news
this morning all the delusion broke a
bit
Sean Hannity that scumbag
has been talking about a 2015 policy
that Barack Obama instituted to regulate
rail cars
caring toxic chemicals
and he keeps acting like that that
regulation was taken off of the rail
cars no that's not what what it was
finally this morning Ducey on Fox and
Friends had to admit live on air that no
I actually um and the reason why folks
you know what you want to know the
reason why
you don't want a reason why because
they're being sued because they're
Liars
so they gotta sneak in facts they gotta
sneak it in here and sneak it in there
that way when they go to court
when they go to court
they got plausible deniability oh well I
mean of course I mean once we discovered
once we discovered the truth we reported
the truth everyone thinks they're going
against Trump it's not they're doing
nothing in Trump's interest or Trump's
disinterance it's only in their interest
only
what what makes you think that the
Republican scumbags over at Fox News
have anything but their own power and
their own money and interest
out of here Rupert Murdoch the only
reason why you like Trump is because it
gave him power and money
not because he loved Trump
this country this country needs to
pluck its head out of its ass
I'm gonna do it if I have to I'm gonna
I'm I'm gonna grab this country by the
shoulders stick my foot on your ass
cheek and pluck it out
foreign there is no reason
at all
outside this stupid timeline
that we're in
for the former president United States
who is under uh going to be indicted
for trying to steal elections
and stealing our documents and then
obstructing justice he's going to be
indicted on those charges mark my words
doubt me you just time stamp it
it's February 23rd Thursday 12 14 a.m or
12 14 p.m on the East Coast sorry
it's 11 where I'm at am
this Market he's gonna be
griffs his supporters the
biggest fraud the biggest financial
fraud probably ever
placed on a group of people
in the history of ever ever
and he does the same thing over and over
and over and they love it
do you have any idea when I grew up in a
rural town like East Palestine Ohio I
grew up in a rural town in Missouri
very similar our railroad there wasn't a
rare there used to be a railroad in our
town there used to be a shut that
down
didn't exist anymore that Railroad
no factories no real jobs there was one
Factory
but all the factories got shipped
overseas because of Republicans
not one in that town
would want to see some Elite
from New York some Real Estate Mogul
from New York flying on his private
plane
with their money
and throw hats at them and sign
autographs as if he's doing something
during a crisis in that town
they would have kicked his ass they
wouldn't even let him within a thousand
miles of that no
way no how I I went to carry you
I go to karaoke on Wednesdays
and at the karaoke that I go to there's
a bunch of you know crusty old white
dudes
and I'm not gonna say who they are on
here but I know who they are
I know who they are I know what they do
for a living
and um
they're Republican I know this for sure
I don't have to guess I know it
and they always sit at a table together
and last night one of them got up
one of the dingiest of them got up
and started singing Song of the South by
Alabama
and in the song song of the sound I
don't know if you know this it talks
about the Great Depression
talks about southern Democrats
it talks about Roosevelt saving them
and that that during the Depression they
were on a farm they were so poor they
couldn't even tell they couldn't even
tell
but Roosevelt made it to where they can
move to town
they get a job they can buy a car a
house have a life have a lifestyle
other than eating dirt pies
out on the farm
and here they are oh and they love that
song Song of the South
sweet potato pie shut my mouth they love
it all right love it
they have no idea what the words mean
white rural people have lost their way
they bought into Q Anon they bought into
white supremacy
let me tell you something in this
country
rural people used to be the ones who
would tell the Elites from New York
flying in on private planes
using them as props would tell them to
off I mean they would have they
would have showed up with double barrel
shotguns
to make sure that didn't
get off the plane
and now we flip the script
how is it how did we get here
and how do we turn it back
that's the question
well we got a few choices
you can either play into their narrative
and be a political prop that they're
using
or you can create your own
that's what the we should do save
our democracy
because you think if you think that the
imagery in Ohio over the last two days
Donald Trump arriving and
feeding feeding these people toxic ass
Trump water which I'm going to tell you
what the Trump water is here in a second
I'm gonna tell you what it is innate 13
year old water
I I mean unless I have proof of that I'm
gonna tell you what the this
is
feeding them Trump water
and signing signing Trump hats out of
McDonald's
Jesus Christ
and these people like oh he's Jesus
Jesus is here he's got hats and he's got
water
how'd this happen how'd it happen oh
where's mayor Pete
where's Joe Biden as if Biden and Peter
welcomed in that town anyways
listen I'm telling you the people in
that town would probably throw eggs at
mayor Pete if he wasn't protected
and I'm not just I'm saying
a a straight white dude in that town
good gay dude in that town nope no
he would not be safe
not in this political climate you think
do you think you think
Governor dewine told Joe Biden to
off
you think there's not a reason why
dewine told Biden to off
I mean I'm not saying that the wine is
taking money from Norfolk Southern but I
I would I would suggest the people look
into it thank you
I would suggest to see what donations
dewine has gotten from companies like
like the one that is continuing causing
derailments
because they're only living up to the
expectations that we give them folks
Norfolk Southern only lives up to the
expectations that we the government we
the people give them
we don't regulate they don't give a
and frankly if we elect if we the people
elect officials to be corrupt
and to not to not go for
our interest and go for corporations
interest when you vote Republicans in
you are making a choice
that now the lobbyists for Norfolk
Southern can go into an office of a
corrupt who doesn't give a
about you and can deregulate the
out of their industry because they
know that's why they put Republicans
there in the first place
not in your interest in their interest
this used to be a thing you in
That Song of the South
even in that song
you can't uh when they're talking about
Teddy or excuse me Franklin Delano
Roosevelt FDR
you can't get a republican to vote like
that
in the interest of the people
you dial the clock back and of course A
lot of people are going to give me
oh my god well Southern Democrats they
were the racist and blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah yeah you're still not
getting the context in the history that
I'm trying to tell you here
you're still not understanding it
even all the way back then the
Republican party was not for the Working
Man
they weren't they still aren't
the only reason why it's confusing is
because they have mind these
people
into believing that some fat slob in a
private airplane a billionaire
and a private airplane comes in a suit
signed some hats that he bought with his
supporters money to go give away
and he probably owns the company that
makes the hats
same way with the water here's the water
you want to know what the water is you
know the story about the water
you want to know it okay apparently
Trump has water and there was a
corporation oh my trump water or
whatever the I don't know who gives
a and and it was closed 10 years
ago or 13 years ago with some dumb
listen what he's doing is he's white
labeling water
you anyone anyone can go bulk order
labeled water whatever the you want
to put on it
you don't have to have a business name
it doesn't have to have name
doesn't matter you just go white label
you can say Trump toxic water on the
white label he's white labeling
it the reason why he was only limited to
the amount that he could white label and
he had to bring other water he said much
much lower Quality Water it's same thing
water same thing water same bug model
just different label is because it took
them longer to White Label that water
that's all I did
I I know a lot of people want to make a
big fuss out of the water and I'm all
for it that that the idea that this 13
year old water is sitting in a in a
Warehouse somewhere come on now
out of here
you think he would pay to keep something
in a warehouse besides classified
documents get out of here he white
labeled it he needed a few days to put
together a white label they put together
white label delivered a pallet a white
label water and three pallets or
whatever else I don't know how many
pallets I'm just surmising here
foreign
funds his supporters money that
he's grifted him from to buy this
and I almost bet I almost bet that he
used one of his stupid shell
corporations as as the
wholesaler for this white labeled water
almost bet you
yeah why wouldn't he stick the profit in
his pocket why not why not
and then go toss a few hats at people
go order some McDonald's
mayor Pete is working he's got a
hard hat on
he's out at the wreck site like on the
ground at the wreck site
he's talking to the officials not not
not cow Towing to the residents
there as they're cheering him on and
worshiping him as if he's some kind of
Messiah
he's working he's doing his job
and the reason why Ohio is having a
problem in East Palestine
Palestine Palestine whatever the
they call it there I mean in Missouri we
call it Washington not Washington
Washington
just saying
and then uh Cairo
we say a cairu here in Missouri there's
a Cairo Missouri spelled Cairo though
but it's Cairo you got different names
different places right
it's why when people tell me oh you're
saying the name wrong like am I really I
mean okay you you and some people say oh
well you're doing it disrespectfully I'm
like that's just the that's just I'm
just moving along look I can't spend
enough time to figure out
exactly how everyone pronounces their
names
I'm reporting I'm going for it we're
doing commentary I'm telling you what
the going on the sound that comes
out of my mouth as long as you know who
the I'm talking about we're in good
shape folks
but in Ohio
the people in that town who voted for
Trump twice who voted for dewine who
voted for JD Vance
are to blame for their Town being being
trudged with toxic chemicals
and they're also to blame for the lame
ass cleanup that's going to happen here
because Republicans aren't in charge of
it and the reason why is because the
governor of Ohio has told the federal
government the EPA FEMA and Joe Biden to
off we don't want your help we
don't want your money we don't want you
nosing in what happened here because we
know what will happen
we know you'll tell the truth
and when you tell the truth it won't be
good for us
so what we're going to do is we're going
to try everything we can to spin our
fake ass fraudulent narrative about this
trained derailment
just like we do with all the mass
shootings just like we do with what we
did with coronavirus and the millions of
deaths there just like we do with the
anti-backs sentiment in this
country every every thing I mean
Jesus Christ folks Jim Jordan is still
thinking about Hunter Biden's this
morning
is where the is Jim Jordan
where is he is he on the ground there in
Ohio where the is he where the
is you Jim Jordan that's your state
right get your ass there and do
something
you're out of your mind if you're not
aware why this derailment happened and
you're out of your mind if you can't
figure out how in the we can stop
it from happening again don't vote
Republican that is how you stop this
vote people in who will look at the
railroad lobbyists and tell them to get
bit
take a hike and if you think oh
well Democrat Democrats are just the
same Tony they'll do this you are a dumb
in 2015 the Democrats put regulations on
these railroad cars
costing costing these these TR these
these freight companies millions of
dollars to upgrade their cars
and they got Republicans to turn it off
Republicans didn't put it on and
Republicans turned it off Democrats did
it if you think if you think for a
goddamn second that it wasn't Democrats
that were pushing for 35 insulin for
every in this country
who needs insulin you are a stupid
bastard this idea that somehow Democrats
are the exact same okay tyt
yeah yeah I'm gonna go after you yep I'm
gonna do it I don't give a
oh they're the same yeah it's the same
thing they'll just oh they're corrupt
too Tony they call out corrupt Democrats
stop voting Republican and stop playing
into their narrative especially you
pro-democracy coalition
stop doing it
the idea
that Joe Biden who had the the Ukraine
trip planned for God knows how long
weeks months probably do you have any
idea the work that they had to do to
make sure that the president United
States could touch the ground in Kiev
do you have any idea
do you think do you think Joe Biden just
woke up that morning's like hey let's go
visit zielinski let's go do that today
what do you think do you think the
preparations for that trip were prior
to what I mean you pick out whichever
rain trained derailment that you
want to pick out but if you want to be
specific you can pick this one out in
Ohio
you know how hard it is to get
regulations on corporations oh my God
it's a it is a to
get regulations on on corporations and
the reason why is because they outgun us
with money in Washington they really do
they oh my God you can't imagine how
much money they spend not just
in Washington but in state houses too
I've seen lobbying bills that
corporations have paid for to make sure
that the regulations that they have are
the way they want them I've seen them oh
my God the lobbying bills holy
oh my God you can't imagine what money
we're up against do you know one thing
they don't have
they do not have our numbers
they cannot outnumber us
they can't
they can't outnumber us
why the do do we do this to
ourselves
ask that question to your family your
friends if some bonehead that you know
Ukraine and he abandoned Ohio he offered
federal assistance long before he
went to Ukraine to dewine
and dewine told him to stick his federal
assistance up his ass
a republican that Ohio voted for that's
not in a gerrymander district
you excuse makers out there
yeah I'm talking to you some of the
audience has been saying this to me I
don't give a though I don't care we
have to get our narrative
straight we have to get our heads on
right here if we're going to win
I I posted my video there's a video clip
social media clip another thing I always
there's two things in government right
there's two things there's two things at
play in government and politics
two things
there's the governing and the policy
part right that's the line items and the
bills and the regulations all the great
stuff that smart people and smart policy
makers do or shitty and
dumb don't do
because it depends on who you elect
because that's the next thing in
politics is elections
you know what's more important than
governing you know what's more important
than governing oh we gotta have good
government
we got to make sure there's not one or
two corrupt Democrats
we got to make sure we gotta make sure
that they're giving every single Last
Ship that they can to every single
person in this country
you know what's more important than that
elections
electing those smart policy makers
without elections you don't get to
govern the corporations do what don't
you understand about this
hey Ohio if you keep voting for your
representatives to go represent
corporations like Norfolk Southern
you're going to get the same
results
same over and over and over and
over
is it the corporation's fault
sure they're responsible they should be
held accountable
but Ohio voted for it baby that's what
they voted for oh they voted they voted
for that big money Norfolk Southern
lobbying oh baby did they vote
for it they voted for that
representation and if you
think it's going to stop with JD Vance
oh baby you got another thing
coming
JD Vance has got six years of
representing Ohio corporations and Big
Business in Ohio you stupid bastards
don't go anywhere I'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show you need to
tell I'm a little pissed off
[Music]
I don't know if Naomi's mad at me he's
calling out PYT
she thinks the guy with the hat
on
oh she thinks I don't know maybe Naomi's
on my side here I can't remember he says
tyt is what happens when noobs take
advice for oh I think she's knocking tyt
I think you're on my side name never
mind never mind I you know when I read
these comments sometimes it's hard for
me to know right because sometimes
you're talking to each other
um sometimes you're not let's do this
let's do this
um what what
did we call this segment where I chant
with you you ask me questions and I chat
with you
um what did we call it didn't we have a
name for it where are we coming up with
names for it like Tony talks or some
shoot the that's what it was
shoot the hey let's uh let's shoot
the for a second
and I I need to get an intro song for it
like a noise a sound like we do for the
list
or bonehead of the week
so I and maybe I'll work on getting a
sound and like a graphic for you for uh
shooting a so let's shoot the
for a minute uh Steve has a question
here he says um why do I have to search
every day for this show I'm no
idea
he used to ask me to join it's probably
because
it's probably because YouTube's like
this motherfucker's crazy
you crazy some I mean you're on
Facebook so you're not on YouTube Steve
I don't know
I mean maybe Facebook's like man he's a
crazy bastard it's possible what do you
can do Steve is you can go follow uh at
the Tony Michaels on Facebook just go
follow at the Tony Michaels on Facebook
and I I broadcast to my page and we also
broadcast to the Midas touch page so
it's on either one of those
um and we used to get more views on
Facebook so I don't know maybe maybe
Facebook
is cutting back on um letting the
guy talk I don't know who knows
I don't know they they really
listen
there's some that are terrified
of how I say we had Rachel bidikoff
run yesterday she's a good friend of
mine we became good friends because of
this show let me tell you a story so I
am and what I'm gonna answer your
questions maybe you got some questions
about that but Rachel we had a golfer
I messaged her and said hey will you
come on the show because I found out
about her and I was like oh my God I
gotta have her on the show
and she didn't know who the I was
she had no clue who I was out of nobody
I'm a nobody now but you know then it
was even worse
and she comes on the show me Gabe
interviewer and um we kind of talked to
her off camera because we recorded the
interview
and she was like this is the greatest
thing ever no one's doing this I'm like
yeah no I know spread the word spread
the word no one no one says the I
say the way I say it no one you won't
find it
good luck if you can find if you can
find a show like this on the left
point it out to me
send it to me I I mean go in a big
search of left-wing media and see if
they do it the way I do it okay let's
take some questions here let's see if I
can find them sometimes this is
difficult and we're going to shoot in
the here so so get your questions
in the chat here it doesn't matter which
platform you're on unless you're on
Twitter if you're on Twitter I can't see
your comments Twitter's a it's
Elon what am I supposed to what
am I supposed to do if you're over
watching on Twitter and most people
don't watch on Twitter because it's
like Periscope is so if
you're on Twitter watching because
you're usually about a dozen two dozen
three dozen people watching on Twitter
but what I do is I post the YouTube link
on top of the Twitter post and I
mean the only reason why I still that's
the only reason why I still broadcast to
Twitter to be quite honest with you
that's the only reason is
because you can see the show is on and
you can click the YouTube link
so you come over and chat on YouTube
when I go into my anal Analytics
for that broadcast to Twitter that's the
only reason why I still do it is because
you guys click on that damn thing so
much like like you click on it to come
to the show so that's one way you find
the show not Steve if you're on Twitter
you can see it there it's got the
YouTube link but if you're watching on
Facebook follow me okay let's hear I'll
shoot the let's see
um
uh um someone on Twitch uh Papa soup 60
ask what happens first Trump indicted
Ukraine liberated oh Trump indicted yeah
for sure 100
oh yeah that that's coming quick and I
don't know if uh Jack Smith is going to
indict him before Georgia Georgia's got
to do their criminal uh grand jury so
that might take a little bit of time
um but Ukraine's nowhere near being
liberated
um and Putin is is signaling that I mean
it's in Putin's best interest like his
own personal best interest to
wind down this
this
Siege on a sovereign democracy like
Ukraine the war crimes that he's
committing it's hidden his best interest
but he's not going to do that
I mean that's the way it was uh let's
see here do
uh Mark asked this is kind of off topic
but Mark asked Tony I think the Supreme
Court is clear and present danger love
to hear your thoughts about how to
message this better and put pressure on
political balance on the court you want
to know how to get political balance on
the court
get 60 United States senators in
the in the party of democracy that's how
you do it
I mean you gotta have Democratic
president you got to have majority in
the house
and you gotta have 60 members
because you got to break that
filibuster
and then we can expand the court
past nine
I mean that that's that's what needs to
happen
well it happened I you know I don't know
I mean there's a lot of ideas on how to
make the Supreme Court better for our
democracy
um I actually there's kind of a hybrid
model of the Supreme Court which I think
should be our main push but again
I don't talk about policy points here
that don't exist right because I could
sit here and bore you marked to death
about oh well here's this option and
here's that option and goddamn let me
give you let me give you the data and
this is how most Americans in a poll no
that
do we need to change the Supreme Court
fundamentally abso lutely you
know how we do that we get our messaging
together to where we can elect policy
makers who will understand that
fundamentally our court does not
represent the majority of America
and restructure it to where it does
in the most efficient way that we
possibly can
there are a lot of ideas out there a lot
of good ideas some of them suck some
kind of suck some of them are pretty
good some of them are really good ideas
but who gives a what those ideas
are it doesn't matter you can have all
the ideas in the world what the
good is it going to do
if you don't do the work of engaging in
your democracy and people don't you
don't get people to engage in democracy
it ain't going to make a Bings were
the difference and they know it
they know what I hope that answers your
question
let's see what else we got
um
a lot of people um
agree with me on the tyt statement
um
uh
Eric has a question I don't see it
Margie but she's she's feeding it to me
here so I can see it it's hard to see
all these questions it really is because
I get all the chat from all the places
so I get it all in one feed uh let's see
says favorite band
you know I don't really have a favorite
band I got a lot of songs I like I grew
up on 80s and 90s country like Classic
Gold Country that's that's the music
that I like
uh I mean
you know this is what I grew up on and
usually the that you listen to as a
kid is the stuff that's closest to Your
Heart Right so it was um it was it was
definitely definitely Classic Gold
Country 80s 90s you know Garth Brooks
George Strait yeah that kind of stuff
um Brian points out this ain't a
question but wrestling ball to the left
yeah the antifa Lim ball the last thanks
Brian uh let's see uh Matt says you're
the best I agree I am the best of this
I'll Pat myself on the back why not
it
um let's see do we have any more
questions
um
tanks launched against
okay um here's one about Twitter will
says uh ask have we talked about the
calculated attack Elon Musk launched
against the working
in the middle classes to utterly just
utterly destroying Twitter I mean and
Elon Musk his goal is not to
launch an attack against working or
middle class
yeah okay his his his goal is to win an
information War
right that's what that's what his
suitors want
the people the people that Elon Musk I
don't know if you watch like the
investor meetings
they're Saudis
it's Saudi Arabia that owns Twitter not
Elon elon's just in charge of
that he's the puppet okay they
loaned him the money Elon I mean
Elon owns Twitter but he doesn't own
Twitter you got a mortgage on your house
do you have a mortgage
try not paying your mortgage for about a
half a year see who owns that
house
you'll find out who actually owns that
I don't own Twitter I mean he runs it
it's his it's got his name on it
but he has to pay the loan
or he he won't own Twitter I mean the
minute the minute these
understand that Elon cannot pay back the
loan they'll they're gonna snatch that
some from him
let's see what else we got here any
other questions
and and by the way it's the Saudis
information War right it's the
information war that they wanna they
wanna with and they know
um Twitter is king ding-a-ling when it
comes to information
because it's the fastest delivery system
for information like that's that's what
makes Twitter work and and the
infrastructure is already built to
deliver that to billions of people in
the quickest most efficient way in small
characters
Twitter is very efficient uh that's
that's why it's so attractive as a
social media platform for news
and and things that are breaking
let's see what else we have
do
um questions I like shoot the the
problem is I gotta figure out we gotta
figure out a better way to um we gotta
figure out a better way to find missions
I might have to have the moderator on my
software and I've talked to a few of
them about this to have them on my
software so that they can see the
questions and then they can highlight
them and then I can go through the
highlighted list
as opposed to the entire list because
it's a lot
it's a lot of stuff we got a lot of
sparklers in here today I see I see
Hal's name popping up a lot as I'm
scrolling through the um the feed here
if you if you're a sparkler shout out to
the sparklers I love having the
sparklers on me and I think me and Al
agree on a lot of I have a little
different way of putting it uh than Hal
does my Approach and my style is
definitely different than Hal's
um but me and Hal agree on a lot of
stuff okay let's see Beth says um who
does your intro and outro I love it I
had that since the very beginning Beth
um I actually had a person who does
radio intros and outros I just kind of
gave him what I wanted and they did it
up and and that's what came out the
first cut so what you hear was the very
first cat we didn't even mess with it
um some of that in that intro is my
quotes
the uh the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty you
eating that's um that's Michael of
course him is also my quote
um but
um he did a fantastic job he did a
fantastic job so a lot of people think
that's my voice and it's it's not mine
um it's someone else's and they do the
uh they do the commercial uh bumpers too
it's like the bumpers that you hear
before we go to Commercial and when we
come back same same guy did those
bumpers
um on that that answers the question
I know some of these questions aren't
you know
when will Church someone's got a
question um
Melanie with a great question when will
churches be taxed
will they ever probably not
I mean you vote you keep voting in
Republicans you keep voting in white
Christian nationalists
okay yeah that's gonna help
that's gonna help you know the people
who are benefiting from them be from the
churches being political yeah okay
same thing with the railroads folks if
you if you want if you want better
representation you better start voting
for people who are going to represent
you not drug companies not the
lobbyists not the institution of
the church
you you and your Liberty gotta
start electing people that are for you
and your Liberty
Jesus Christ Joe Biden did a whole
speech on it in Poland the other day
he did a whole speech on it it's amazing
that Joe Biden somehow
isn't isn't showing through that he's
the most democratic president that we've
had small d
guy wants democracy he wants unions I
love you know what's funny about dyd we
were talking about him earlier a lot of
people agree with me in the comments
dyd
um and I I agree with that sentiment
tyt now there's a few voices I mean
we've had Ben gleibon he does tyt I
think Walter matterson I think he does
stuff with dyt he's a friend of mine I'm
not saying that each individual person
with tyt is bad I'm talking about the
entire network as a whole they're
they're they're narrative they
continue to perpetuate self-suppression
they they and they act like both sides
are the same that that doesn't
help
but um I don't know where I was going
with that sorry
I lost my train of thought I got pissed
off get pissed off at dyt uh I may be a
bit hungover too it may happen
how do we think how do I think it ends
for Putin I've said it a million times
P2 ammo sandwich
he's gonna eat an ammo sandwich mark my
words
and that's how Putin that's how Putin
will end
that's how they all end just go look at
what happens to
murderous dictators autocrats they eat
ammo sandwiches either someone feeds it
to them or they eat it themselves
what do I know about the Supreme Court
election April 4th are you talking about
in Wisconsin
Henry yeah see I follow a lot of stuff
um I follow a lot of stuff
but I'm not a Wisconsin show it's like
I mean I can yell and scream about
Wisconsin a lot the problem is is I I
don't that's mine show is a national
show
so there's a strategy there's a method
to my madness I know it doesn't seem
like it sometimes but there truly is
and I talk about it a lot I'm very
transparent with you yesterday I even
coined the phrase pro-democracy
propaganda you could use it go out there
and say I said it quote me pro-democracy
propaganda I dare them to knock it I
dare them to challenge it do it do it
but the point is is that my show is a
national show
my show is for the national narrative
and National messaging because in all
reality that politics isn't local that's
all that's the line
that politicians feed to you to get
Republicans voted in
oh man politics is all local
no it's not no it's not we have one
nation one
we're all in the interest of the nation
we all have state constitutions and you
got to deal with that but we're one
country we're one nation
you know under guide and
so that's that's my that's my aim is to
have a national messaging and the reason
why is because the local
um messaging will follow
I I and I know I I beat this drum over
the last few weeks because Russian ball
is dead
um but that's what kind of makes me the
antifa Limbaugh of the left
right
like that's the whole idea that's the
reason why the show sounds like it does
it's structured like it is is it's uh
because I've had this comment a lot is
why does your show seem like right wing
talk radio because it is
it's it's
I hate to say I stole something but I
stole it because it works it just works
it entertains people it gets people to
come watch every single day over and
over and over again which only gets
people up to speed in Civics right now
instead of shoveling lies down
your throat
I try to give you the cold hard raw
truth right and I don't give it to you
the bunch of facts and
statistics and charts and boring ass
commentary
oh this is MBR no I don't do that
I want you to pay attention I want you
to come back here every
day so I gotta be I gotta be a little
extra every day for you
to keep in the game
because if I can keep you in the game
you get three more people in the game
they get three more people in the game
eventually Henry I got enough people in
Wisconsin when they're talking about a
national narrative I don't have to
mention
Wisconsin specifically I mean we can
talk about the that's going on
there
oh
but that's
that's the whole goal so
um it doesn't matter what I know about
the Supreme Court election in Wisconsin
on the fourth what matters is that I
push the national narrative so that way
we can get we can get to a place where
Wisconsin can pluck its head out of its
ass
and they don't need they don't need
local politics they can file the
national narrative
um and because if you get too drilled
down our national narrative that's where
you get in trouble that's why Bernie
Sanders couldn't win oh gonna piss the
Bernie Bros off what's my favorite food
steak you goddamn right I'm a
steak eater
oh man I love them I love a good rib eye
bone-in rib eye holy that's my jam
bone-in rib eye I know this guy's
favorite food though I mean you asked
this guy what his favorite food is is it
steak is it steak Gabe Sanchez he's
finally here is it steak you like steak
what you're you're muted I don't know
what the hell you have computer problems
you got microphone problems this guy
he's gonna get it I promise you Diane
he'll he'll tell you what his favorite
food is here a second
um anybody got a guest with them Gabe
Sanchez is yeah there you go yeah yeah I
love steak steaks great yeah bone-in
right that's probably my favorite you
know I like that I like that I like size
I like you know good good nice little
some Grizzle you know on the end oh hell
yeah
you kind of cut it up into little pieces
so you can get a little bite on each on
each one because that marble man
steak so good so good do you guys
thought he would be some kind of kale
eating didn't dude I'm from
I'm from the Midwest man I'm born and
raised I throw them away
that's that's the beef capital
of the world baby yeah that's the
capital of the world it is uh I
I mean if I could I would obviously it's
not the healthiest thing to eat all the
time but when you you know put some
maybe a little broccolini on the side
maybe some potatoes steak unhealthy now
because it was healthy now it's
unhealthy yeah
you need eggs and they're like you
should eat eggs it's it's if you eat if
you eat like I think you know we're
eating red meat every single day is
probably not the most healthy thing for
you but anything too much it's not Yeah
well yeah within moderation it's fine
but I mean like you know we uh my
partner and I made steaks uh two weeks
ago and we had some greens on the side
we had some some nice like rustic
potatoes going on dude
so good so good Hannah's got a question
here this is the shoot the thing we
need to make like a graphic and a song
for this for the show
yeah something like that shoot yeah I
don't know yeah
I don't know
um she asked um have you ever known
anyone who got yes converted from them
we do Yeah we actually had Jeremy London
yeah on um and his connection
um got cut a lot but we finally got him
on the phone and he told the story about
his dad so there are people and look I
keep telling you this and I know it
doesn't feel that way because it's a
it's a fraud that the media buys into
yeah that people aren't walking away
from Trump they are that's the whole
point of I'm trying to make with the
santis and him not getting in the race
is I'm trying to wedge that issue right
because if people have to go out and
they have to really start to think about
am I going to support the santis or am I
going to support Trump like they have to
put some thought into it which that's
the process it takes to I don't know
come to a logical conclusion on anything
so this idea when they when they just
when they just go based on their
feelings and the that's that's the
vile that's puking out of Fox News when
they go make their decisions based on
that as opposed to their rationale and
their thought process and their logic
but that's the purpose of wedging a lot
of times it's not just to pit them
against each other but to get the San
the Santa supporters and the Trump
supporters start fighting because you
get them fighting you get them like well
Trump's the one Trump's the one who took
the deregulations away from the train
caused disaster in Ohio imagine if you
get the santis voters Republicans the
Santa's voters blaming Trump for the
derailment in Ohio think about how
beautiful that is that's the narrative
that we need that's the wedges that we
have to drive yeah and we see we see
Republicans and Maga especially they run
into we you know we showed on the show
because they put it out there for us
they literally broadcast themselves
whether it's you know doing a selfie
video or there's some talking head
pundit on some Fox News or right-wing
show
they run right into the point and keep
going through right and they don't
understand what they were just arguing
for which typically is like hey we
should have these these things available
to us is like well we would if your
party didn't try to like you
know nail us into the ground here
and so you see that happen a lot where
people on the right will begin to
realize that there's something wrong
with their party however they don't go
the full way or have the full like
Epiphany which is their parties to blame
then they go oh no it was the Deep State
or the Democrats or the demon rats or
George Soros or Joe Biden they'll come
up with something right it's always some
what about us when really in the end
it's their own party is to blame and you
look at the train derailment you look at
the balloon issue you look at the
Trump water at the and East
Palace you know it's just that's
hilarious it's crazy but you do
see people convert over and sometimes it
can happen within their own party where
they fight enough and then they then
they have the realization that the other
side their side within their party is
bad
and they go oh
and sometimes you have people like
Jeremy who like has a conversation with
his dad and then he comes to be like oh
wow I you know I didn't realize that
I was kind of asked backwards in my way
of thinking right right like I actually
believe the things that aren't Trump
right but I was convinced that I mean
those are what more evidence do you need
to show that Fox News literally knew
they were lying intentionally lied
played the game of manipulation so they
could get you know viewers and
subscribers and people to keep watching
their television or their TV shows right
it's
there's no more evidence than you that
you need to understand that not only
that on top of Tucker Carlson you know
assuming that no reasonable person would
take him seriously none of these people
are real they're not actually they don't
they're I mean they are the Republican
party they don't care about
anyone
what Cynthia asked here she says but
have you converted anyone from your town
okay let me tell you a story so I got a
really good friend about it really close
friend I went to high school with him
he's a good buddy of mine
um he voted for Trump in 16. now what is
really weird and this is this is a thing
that a lot of people don't understand he
in the primaries he was a Bernie
supporter right and then he voted for
Trump okay which is wild stuff right
like those two people are not even close
to the same right but they are and it
that it's all nonsense that Bernie and
Trump are not part of the same yeah
their political establishment it's it's
in that they were at the time in 2016
they were anti-establishment and they
had a very authoritarian tinge to them
that the president can just sign
something and it becomes something right
right and because there was a lot of
angst in the country that sold really
well and that sold to my friend he voted
for Joe Biden in 2020 because he knew
the mistake he he had made in 2016. the
problem is Cynthia is that he's not a
member of the cult and I keep trying to
convey that on here that look the the
people that really worship this buffoon
and are going to go to the end of the
Earth with him is a small percentage of
people maybe 10 to 12 and we may be
getting under 10 at this point in this
country it's a large number of people
because 10 percent of the country is a
is a lot of right it's a
lot of lunatics or balloonatics
whichever you want to say or what do we
call train it takes yeah yeah
derailatics yeah relatives because
everyone's acting like Ohio is the only
derailment with toxic chemicals in the
ground like there's one there was
literally a truck that that had an
accident and Spilled Out nitric acid in
Tucson Arizona
what year was it 21 2013 is that the
last is that when that happened Oh you
mean like last week oh oh last week
Jesus Christ yeah yeah people people are
not listen
the media pushed by Fox News is the
reason why you are hearing anything
about a toxic spill in Ohio and really
the idea that the transportation
secretary go or the president United
States go to every single derailment or
every single time toxic chemicals are
poured out somewhere and a town or
citizens or up property they
that's all they would do that is all
that that's why we have a thing called
bureaucracy so they handle the the work
that needs to be done for us
Pete Buddha judge is not the only one
that works at Department of
Transportation he's not the only
there there's thousands of
bureaucrats that work there that try to
protect us in the interest of us the
government
um so when it's almost it's almost like
if we had uh well you know we talked
about yesterday regulation or
preventative measures in place the same
reason why Health Care would be much
cheaper for any individual if we had
preventative care right if you can
prevent early on then you avoid this
huge cumbersome
uh you know
injury or or you know pain or whatever
it is right this this operation you have
to do same thing with the train
derailment right and you see a lot of
Republicans want to blame uh you know
uh Secretary of Transportation or you
want to blame Biden and then you have
dewine who's like I'm not taking any of
that and you're like how dumb do
you have to be I mean like obviously we
know because you're all trying to plot
against Biden but
it's just like you would think that if
you you know it's the whole thing of
like measure 12 times cut once not
measure once cut 12 times that's exactly
what the Republican Party does they just
like haphazardly for God we're just
gonna do this and then later on you're
like Why didn't it work and it's like
because you guys ruined it you guys took
this stuff away
I could agree with you more on on that
point and and I I'm trying to find this
video there's a video going
around of um of a rail of a freight a
freight rail in Ohio and it looks like
I mean it looks like dogs oh like
it's running but it's in terrible
condition it doesn't even look like you
can uh wait are you telling me that's
like a that's like a infrastructure
thing or like uh right well you would
think you would think if they would have
an infrastructure week they would just
and and like Democrats or Republicans
whichever party would get together and
like I don't pass infrastructure then
maybe they could like I don't know use
the money to fix these things I'm trying
to find that it's like a
viral video now a lot of people are
sitting it around like oh my God I can't
believe and this is again folks this is
how people just don't know how
works because you don't know how to use
Google most the time but listen and I'm
I'm chastising some of you out there
because I've seen a lot of comments from
the left on this like I can't believe
they would put passenger cars on this
rail I'm like that rail is a freight
rail there there are dual rails out
there you have to understand that
there's companies that own the rails
like Amtrak rents on they rent their the
capability of running on a rail okay
they
it's not not all trains run on all rails
and this rail specifically that this
video is apparently in Ohio can't find
that I thought I
retweeted it this morning so I had it
trying to find
you know yeah I'm under the the mayor
Pete oh oh wait wait wait wait wait hold
on it's like a now this video or some
oh I think I don't know it's just
it looks I mean the rail is just like
dog and they gotta yeah yeah I
think I found it I think the train has
to go really slow across this is rail
um is it this one I don't know let me
see let me see if this is it it looks
like shitty tracks I'll tell you oh it's
horrible it's horrible and the reason
why is because it's only a a freight
rail so only freight goes on this rail
yes this is it yeah you're not going to
put people on that of the
country look this one isn't the the
exact clip of it but this um here let me
show it you see that oh my God that
didn't even look like you could run a
train that looks like this is old tracks
right that have shifted based on
environmental issues again right uh
again this is probably Republican issues
a company owns this rail folks they have
the right to build this rail and
maintain this rail on this property
right and here's the thing is that if
if if we as a country go oh my God I
can't believe that we should make the
company fix that you know what the
company is going to say will pay us then
right pay us then pay us
then I mean that's what they're gonna
say it's the same thing as like um when
corporations want to socialize their
profits when they go to like uh big
cities and like hey build us a stadium
for a football team yeah it's going to
bring you a ton of sales tax but we're
going to make you pay for it we're going
to socialize our profits right there's a
lot of socialism in this country folks a
lot hey you socialist out there you
burning Bros you people who love tyt
there's a ton of socialism in this
country
and this is an example of socialism that
we have not given
to a company I mean it's possible that
the infrastructure bill is going to help
fix this problem but it doesn't you just
don't pass a bill and Bam the tracks
appears right I mean that anyhow it
happens but if you watch I'm going to
turn the audio off because there's no
reason to listen to the audio but watch
how this train is you know having to
move at a slow pace just to make
it through this little track of rail
here that is of disaster now this is a
rail this is a freight car there's no
passenger trains on this track no
passenger rail Amtrak is not going to
rent the ability to run its cars on this
track because it's just a Freight track
that's why it's been so neglected is
because the only thing that runs on this
is really heavy Freight and that's the
other reason why it looks like dog
is because the engineering and that it's
just dog because they're going to
spend as less money as they possibly can
here's yeah I mean that's that's typical
you know typical uh
yeah look how slow that is but
that's typical you know uh yeah they
have to slow down to a creep to get past
this section I mean like you would you
would think I'm sure obviously the you
know conductor of the train is like
my life any day now
some stick is going to be on this rail
and it's going to completely
shift this thing off to the side you
want to know because that's a good point
that you bring up as a labor the people
that are working on those trains because
apparently on this one in Ohio
um that everyone's oh oh my God it's the
only derama that's ever happened in the
United States history like get the
out of here
um well it has toxic chemicals even like
yeah okay
um the thing is is that train I think it
had 180 cars is what they said which is
a lot of Freight cars yeah
and I don't remember how many have the
toxic chemicals but there was three
three driving that train
down that track now what you have to
understand too is a lot of these a lot
of these engineers and these people like
a tutu engineer not like an engineer
that draws and builds things different
engineer but the people who are running
the the cars who running the trains that
Rick work for the railroads that work
for like Norfolk Southern these these
folks drive on these tracks every
day they know these tracks are
dog they know they know they need
more than three people on a train to
manage to get over track like we just
saw it it takes way more people on the
train to make sure that that that
cargo is secure across that dog
track and that's that's what
they've been yelling and screaming about
like hey they're firing us it
ain't no wonder you're having
derailments right we can't help you
prevent it when we're not there
and it's also I mean it's it's the same
you see the same behavior or have seen
the same behavior when it came to the
airline industry right they're like look
we'll bail you out okay we're gonna give
you this money so you can use it to keep
things afloat repair your your planes
make sure that everything's good to go
but the condition is you cannot do stock
BuyBacks you cannot use this for this or
that like you cannot benefit your own
Executives if we give you this money if
we if the American people bail you out
and give you this money to help make
this better and keep you guys
afloat you can't do this stuff
wait you're saying you should regulate
and then what happens and then what
happens Tony they take the money they do
stock BuyBacks they do these golden you
know parachutes they do all these other
stuff and then when the next recession
cycle comes through they say oh more
money please
we gave you money to prevent this from
before right like yeah well we didn't do
the thing that you told us that we you
know yeah let's see what happened what
happened was this we we lobbied to get a
bunch of Republicans elected that way
they didn't hold us accountable to why
the reason why we needed to to make sure
this money was used in a certain way
because of the American taxpayer gave it
to us and the American taxpayer by God
they picked they picked the political
party that was against their interest
wouldn't you know it huh yeah that's
kind of crazy funny it's kind of funny
how that happens
um okay so I a few more questions then
let's go to the Shameless Roundup yeah
because
um we're gonna back it up here to the
stakes because I got a few questions on
the stakes and I'd like to take these
questions is coming after my Stakes
Maybe he's coming after those gas stoves
and apparently now he's going to come
after a toxic chemical waste cleaning oh
wow you know dare he that's true
canceling canceling toxic cleanups
before I go to this question you know
it's really funny because I brought this
up during the first 30 minutes did you
see how fast JD Vance became an
environmentalist like just like that
he's in the Creeks waving a stick around
this is disgusting
you are the party you're the party who
poisoned people in Detroit with
lead pipes and and still don't want to
do it still yeah they're like oh they
went in prison yeah and let's I just
want to remind everyone the day the
train derailment happened yeah he's
taken a little selfie with his
gun like he's gonna shoot down the
Chinese Bible that's what he was doing
and then it took him 10 days 10 days to
respond and say this is what my office
has as an official statement 10 days
days and now he wants to back the green
new deal with AOC all of a sudden holy
dude it's it is crazy you it's
almost like the Republican party has to
kill people
I mean like you saw the same thing with
covid right for a while they were like
oh yeah joke's on you
we're coming for you Democrats and then
like oh wait our constituents are dying
oh okay um wear a mask uh get a
vaccine if you want to but by that point
everyone was like Boo people were booing
Lindsey Graham right when he was like
hey looks like the next uh variant is
pretty bad get the vaccine and was like
Boo Boo and it's like well I mean you're
doing everything they can they're doing
everything they can to convince people
that Republicans didn't that up
yeah like anything they can because
they're like in desperation they're like
President Trump made all of these
vaccines and it's like no we didn't
because the vaccines are working the
treatments are working they figured out
how to treat it the hospitalizations
even when you get hospitalized you're
you're less likely to die now I mean it
just it's crazy preventative care it's
crazy it's crazy that it's crazy that
science and the medical community has
come up with a way to treat cobit it's
really it's really I mean it also
doesn't out that Jared Kushner was
heading the vaccine or the covid uh kind
of control and then says oh you know
what those blue States and it's
like dog the blue states are keeping the
red States afloat so right good luck I
didn't mean to get off on covid but
here's the question uh how do I like my
steak uh she said Nan says she likes
hers medium I like rare
um
I like a I like a nice a nice medium
rare seared I wanted pink in the middle
yeah I like you know nah I want to blah
I want the blue bloody oh well have you
ever seen Cowboy Way with Woody
Harrelson and Keith everyone so they
they they're cowboys and they go to New
York and they go in this fancy
restaurant and like how would you like
it he said that just knock its horns off
wipe its nasty old ass and slap it on
down on the plate that's the best way to
describe how I like my steaks knock its
horns off and wipe its nasty old ass
um and let's see here uh grass-fed HK I
hate that I hate to break it to you but
grass-fed steak versus green fence steak
dude you're missing out I mean I know
it's all oh man oh yeah I want to be
organic and healthy and but listen
we we would we would grain feed our
steak I'm not I'm not saying steak we
would go to the store to buy we would
have our our Black Angus steers in the
backyard and we would be feeding them
green and then we would take them to the
Butcher House and piss my mom off
because we would name them they were
almost like pets and then when you're
sitting there eating the you know you're
like um this is a good you know whatever
their name was Burger you know like oh
my God oh my God you're like
that but listen grass-fed I get it I get
it but grain fed steak's way better
um Gabe they're asking or telling you
Gabe sporting
no it's just I I took a shower and I put
uh in my hair so now it's like yeah
stuck you know yeah it's kind of like I
think most of the time he makes it to
the shower before he gets on the show
Mostly yeah most of the time or some
days you can tell sometimes you've got
the slobber still on yeah
I Gotta Wait sometimes a few minutes
because he's still like when he comes in
the green room I can see him on camera
like that yeah like I'll be I'll come
back from walking the dogs and then I'll
be like I'm still kind of like not with
it like I just need five more minutes
it's like when you're a kid and you're
in bed and you're like all right five
more minutes and your mom's like get the
up now and you're like okay I'm
getting up I'm getting up and then the
next thing you realize is there's a
whole comforter that's been
pulled out from under or from on top of
you and then you're in the cold in you
know it's winter time like so
cold and she's like all right get the
up let's go we're gonna be late for
school that's right well my daughter did
the same thing this one you set the
alarm she's she said five minutes and
then she she has you know do you ever
get water dumped on you
did I yeah no I mean we're in a spray
bottle yeah my dad my dad when he was if
I would wake up he'd come in with like a
he'd be yelling and screaming and
pounding on pots and pans and you
know and stuff like that oh so like a
New Year's kind of Celebration yeah well
I mean you know you gotta wake your ass
up you know wake your ass up and we
didn't live like an apartment so you
didn't worry about waking other people
up yeah yeah everybody's already awake
so uh is that all the questions again I
think that's all the questions we got
somebody somebody said oh Laura Palmer
asked me if the if the whiteboard's
coming back yeah I've been I would I was
traveling I know I'm sorry it's coming
let's let's look look at the scene it's
coming it's coming back up but here's
the thing before when I had where my
other position of the desk was I could
have the Whiteboard much closer but now
based on where the desk is I have to
shift it so this is like so you're gonna
have to get thicker markers
yeah probably I might have my I have my
little like my I have my markers right
here but see when we're in this view you
can see his stuff really well but when
we go to this view you won't be able to
so then it's all the way over by the
door right I can't do that see and then
see like mine there's mine yeah and then
there's both but I don't have here's the
thing I don't have this room then it
cuts out a lot of I know I like this one
better I don't have a I don't have like
a second office like Tony does I live in
uh oh God damn oh God damn
it's my white privilege showing you yeah
I'm just saying man the privilege you
have to own a home listen here's here's
the thing is in Missouri it's it's a
hell of a lot cheaper I bet I bet my
mortgage for my four bedroom house is a
hell of a lot cheaper than you would
ever dream of paying for rent for one
bedroom oh probably that's just somebody
somebody says I could put it on the back
door here on the door
yeah it might be hard like I said you're
going to get something
then if I sit like this maybe and then
you have it right there now cut back to
the other View
yeah you catch some of it that's
responsibility because I got a for
my TV yeah to my TV and I used to play
like on on the screen I'd play like news
or something people like that's
distracting so then I put the logo there
but if you don't if you don't know watch
this watch this if I move let's see if I
move this way see the wires there yeah I
I was like oh I gotta hide these wires
and I'm like no I don't I hide them yeah
what the hell I don't even know this
it's all illusion there's like a cone to
clean this here too you know like
there's a camera yeah everything outside
but that's the thing also directly
behind me is the door that leaves the
bedroom and that's a closet right there
so like I don't have yeah because that's
the corner we used to see behind you
yeah so that's the other side so now
I've literally flipped it from the other
side of the room you know I see I had to
make my one bedroom feel a little bit
new wow yeah he needed more fun shway
you know what they call it Fung shui
um let's see let's let's uh we have any
more let's do this let's go to the
list because I got I got all kinds of
videos to show you today there's tons of
Clips never run out of them let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
the list
welcome welcome back to the show you
reached about a show we round up all the
Tweet tweets training trains we got tons
of Clips to get to so let's get to him
this first one Gabe Sanchez Fox News has
been wine for a week Sean handed his
life
well about uh easy let me finish damn it
about this trained derailment John
Hannity for weeks has been saying Barack
Obama passed a policy back in 2015. well
this morning Fox News apparently found
out that the policy that Barack Obama
was for the regulations
prevented this from happening right so
you mean the one that Trump
overturned in 2017 I think is what it
was I think there's actually a tweet of
it and I've got to find it but you're
telling me that yeah
he was bragging about it yeah he was
like oh we got to get rid of this Obama
era regulation
got toxic chemicals everywhere and then
I'll show up with water and Maga heads
and everything will be cool but this is
the I mean this is this is here here
this is something imagine what would
have happened I mean I'm sure they would
have blamed democrats for this as well
but imagine what would happen let's say
that Trump did win a second term right
God forbid he won a second term but
let's say he won a second term and this
train to Roman happened because there
was nothing that Trump did or was doing
that would have prevented this if
anything it would have probably
exacerbated and we probably had more
Trend romance that would have happened
but oh dude melting into the abyss he'd
be like EPA we're not doing the EPA we
don't even have an EPA we literally
appointed someone to run the EPA to undo
the EPA like yeah to get rid of it I
mean that's yeah he was was like oh you
want to save these natural resources
and so that's the same thing but yeah I
can only imagine if Trump was still
uh if Trump is still
or or was re-elected as president right
now and this train derailment happened
because again nothing that Trump would
have done would have prevented this from
happening and also the nothing would
have
helped the situation if Trump was in
office to actually alleviate relocate uh
help you know create a fund because
here's the other thing I guarantee
there's going to be uh has it if anyone
hasn't seen it I actually randomly I
just watched this movie last night it's
very good it's with Michael Keaton
um it's called Uh it's called worth
and he is this
Insurance claim adjuster he's a lawyer
but they but basically what they do is
they look at events and they say okay
what is the value or worth of a life
okay and his firm was in charge of
figuring out the September 11th victim
Relief Fund right how much that life was
worth and how much they you had to
determine you know based on this
calculation what the life was worth
right and at first he started like oh
well it's based on income and then
um Stanley Tucci was another character
who was like no no you got to rethink
all this stuff and his wife had had lost
uh her life in in uh in the towers of 9
11.
so that movie funny enough I just
watched last night and I guarantee
that firm might be in charge of this
because he's also worked he's also
because this is this is a this is a
fictional movie but it's based on real
events no no well it's a it's it's
non-fiction it's based on a real like
he's the real guy that was in charge of
it and right I know but it's Michael
Administration oh yeah yeah in that
sense yes it is it's an interpretation
of the yeah but it's based on a real
story an event that happened but he's
also a documentary is what I'm no no no
but he's also been in charge
Virginia Tech shooting uh there's
several other mass shootings unfortunate
this guy this is like what he does yeah
and this is what he does now and so I
wouldn't be surprised if his firm is now
in charge of this of loss of life or
compensation or anything like that
um because that's what's gonna happen
right you're you're gonna have to have a
firm come in and they're going to have
to appraise property value because
everyone keeps bitching about Biden and
the federal government the EPA is
already is already whole going to be
holding
um Norfolk Southern accountable for
their actions here they're saying look
you're gonna pay for this yeah you're
gonna pay for it and and that's why
people are urging citizens in that town
not to sign anything that has Norfolk
Southern on it like do not sign do not
sign I mean does anyone does anyone
remember Aaron Brockovich like
right and actually she's been tweeting
about and she went to you there's anyone
that needs to show up in that town it
it's that she's gonna go
through I mean like if anyone remembers
that movie or that story in Hinckley uh
about Hinckley water I think is what the
it was absolutely water uh that movie
Aaron Brockovich with Julia Roberts
right exactly but if you remember
much Beyond just oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
but I saw that she tweeted the other day
yeah oh yeah she was and she was like
she was tweeting at JD Vance like you
scumbag you didn't you didn't
say anything about this for 10
days where the were
you ten days ago she right she doesn't
give you because Aaron Brockovich
is a is a real liberal folks
she's a real dude she's a badass
man she is she's a bad well
here's Fox News and they gotta report
this here's why they have to report the
truth at some point so they sneak it in
in these spots where there's a lot of
viewers and they you know they always do
this one little clip where they say the
truth for about two seconds and then
they jump back to the non-truth that way
when they end up in court they'd be like
well we we we kind of said the truth you
know it's entertainment but you know
whatever I hear here's a clip of fox and
friends uh trying to sneak in their
little truth bite here back to White
House right uh speaking of the White
House apparently regulation
regarding train safety were changed
during the Trump Administration
um
he goes apparently oh apparently we're
just finding out you know what's funny
is he literally tweeted about it in
2017. bragged about it they're they're
bitching that Pete Buda judge is on the
ground today a day after Trump right
only the day so how why did it take
Trump so long to get to to East
Palestine Palestine how do you say how
do they say it in Ohio am I getting
right Palestine because you know in
different Missouri as you say Washington
we say Washington yeah different than
Palestine it's East Palestine I have to
remember that sometimes too because I
remember you know Palestine right yeah
East Palestine Ohio this little town in
Ohio
um try why did it take Trump so long to
show up at this wreckage that he's
responsible for Gabe Sanchez that's what
I want to know why why did it take why
did it take Trump so long to show up at
this wreckage that if he is is
responsible for well he had a couple
weddings that he had to drift off at
Mar-A-Lago he had to wave to some fans
across the street he had to make a few
videos that probably takes hours it was
fake President's Day it was like
President's Day uh so I want to show you
speaking of that grifter
um grifting off his supporters and
making a mockery of this here's a
picture this is in a McDonald's
and he's Palestine Ohio okay now he went
there I'm my best guess is that Donald
Trump owns a company who makes these
hats and then he sells those tats to his
campaign right that's how much of a
corrupt scumbag he is well yeah that not
probably I mean they're all they're also
no not probably that's what he does yeah
yeah yeah there's no way he buys
them from someone else he's got a
company he's got a company and he he
makes the hats and then that company
sells those hats to his campaign see
that's how he takes his he grips his
supporters right to get that money and
political dollars and then he puts it in
his own pocket by selling like nfts and
and and hats and Trump water right yeah
because that's I mean do you want to
know where the factory is
for for these hats specifically I mean
I'm I'm sure it's in America right
actually
well at least in uh this is in
2018. this was
though he has other products that are
made in China so but this one
specifically uh the hats are produced by
a california-based company called Cali
Fame
in California though whoa whoa whoa why
are a bunch of libtards making Maga hats
radical leftist lunatics are making
money
um 80 of the company's employees yeah
are Latino what the no I I would
almost bet I would almost bet that they
climbed over if we would have a wall
that they wouldn't you know what I mean
this is so this is in 2018. so I
don't know they could uh they could be
other I mean in 2020 fact check official
Mega hats are made in America unofficial
vendors made somewhere else well I mean
here's here's the rub here's the rub so
when Trump does this he'll go to several
factories right not him his yeah his hat
people right the people running the Hat
grift they'll go to these factories to
figure out who's going to give them at
the lowest cost that's why he's going to
California yep in this Factory because
he's hiring them to build his hats the
the Trump hat Corporation will call it
the Trump hat Corporation goes to all
these factories and contracts
a hat factory to build his hats that
he's gonna sell to his to Trump's
campaign that's what happens and that's
what the happens if you don't
believe me go follow money just just
doubt me you can try it won't
work because here he is in he's supposed
to be going supporting these people to
clean up a toxic waste and he goes to
McDonald's of all places to eat toxic
waste and pass out his toxic waste half
I mean isn't that the American dream I
guess it is I guess it is I don't know
and not only that but he also goes there
and he hands out his dumb
Trump water do you think do you think
Pete butterjudge is passing out mayor
Pete hats today and signing oh yeah 100
dude oh he goes he goes it says mayor
Pete I'm gay right
like that's that's probably what it says
and Republicans are like oh my God can
we can we make is are we allowed to make
a hat I don't know
is that not okay
I know it's funny
I know it's funny because because it
really would get underneath their skin
is the reason why I I want it
because I mean no no no one would have a
problem who who is um who's comfortable
with their sexuality with wearing that
oh no I mean I'd wear it I I would wear
it okay Pete I'm gay
but mayor Pete is not passing out hats
today no no no
he's not and I'm just you know you know
what he's handing out he wasn't handing
out um
uh federal assistance empathy and
federal assistance yeah that that's of
course Trump hands out Trump water and
now again I don't know I know that could
be is he throwing paper towels to people
there well who knows well here's the uh
here's the Trump of water here's oh my
God this is so stupid and I'm gonna tell
you what the Trump water thing is too
because everyone's getting it confused
they're like this is 13 no year old
water I'm like it's not 13 year old
water let me explain I'll tell you what
it is here's here's Trump talking about
his water this is a water which is water
especially thanks some of the incredible
people that uh helped us because we're
bringing thousands of bottle of water
Trump water actually
triple water actually
now listen to what he says about the
other water that he's gonna give to
these people because he couldn't get
enough white labeled water with Trump
printed on it in time so he had to get
when did Trump water file for bankrupty
well right but I'm going to tell you why
this is I'll tell you why it's not the
same thing I'm not saying why it's not
saying that let's listen most of it uh
some of it we had to go to a much lesser
Quality Water
so he's admitting in a microphone with
all these people behind him and you
notice a trend here with these people
behind him you see the trend
um but he it's hilarious because he's
like a lower we're gonna give him a
lower quad we're gonna give him low
quality we're going to get you tap water
straight from East Palestine right and
uh I don't know if you guys like it we
might have a little bit interest to it
yeah
what the okay so here's the water
situation right Trump water is the same
thing as the Trump hat Corporation he he
started a water company way back when so
he could sell water to his Resorts he
would make the water he would brand
Trump and then he would sell it to the
Trump property
As Trump water right yeah this is how he
becomes his own supplier in that in that
form now the reason why they probably
filed bankruptcy is so he can make more
money right in the bankruptcy yeah but
what he's doing with this water in East
Palace Palestine or Palestine winner in
Palestine is he's white labeling it and
the reason why he this is he's telling
on himself again yeah you always got to
know that he's telling on himself when
he's talking and what he says is we
brought Trump water but then we didn't
have enough of it so we had to bring
this water that you're not going to
want it's the same Water by the way yeah
just have a different label so he went
he knows he knows the water Factory he
knows the white labeled water Factory
because he's done it before they just
called them up and said hey we need as
much Trump water as you can label as
fast as you can label it they're like
okay we can have this much done like
that's not enough okay well didn't throw
in the other that's what he that's
what he that's what he's saying man
if if there was a comparison of like Ice
Mountain Water yeah uh dizani water
is definitely different yeah yeah well
that one has clear clearer hints of
sodium in there nobody if have you ever
seen photos of like a natural disaster
and people are like raided the
store the only thing leave the designing
water at the bottom shelf nobody
likes Dasani water and if you do
I question if you're actually a human
monster but Trump water I I have
this feeling like people are like I'll
take the designing water over
the Trump water everything yeah hell
yeah I'll take that poison over here did
you see the video of it's an old video
that resurfaced uh yesterday I think
because of this of Sylvester Stallone
saying he would not he was doing a taste
test comparison and it had Trump water
and and other like people take it yeah
let me let me grab it real quick yeah
yeah grab it so I gotta um I got another
clip here speaking of um uh poisoning
Ohio you see JD Vance in the background
here oh there he is he's doing a lot to
help Ohioans man look at Don June he's
like I'm the photo guy
oh he is I didn't see that
back there oh yeah I saw this video last
night is this Rhonda santis is this
Rhonda Santos back here oh that oh my
God or is it like a Rhonda Santa's body
double I think he's a body double it
looks like that looks like I think he's
the one that like Trump like shadow
boxes with you know oh okay I see he he
like calls he just he has a he has a
meatball he has a meatball body double
so he can just call him meatball he's
just he's just like meatball get up here
get up here
meatball Ron and then this and then this
body double comes up I'm meatball Ron
that's all he said yeah I'm meatball run
yeah
yeah that's his whole thing I mean look
uh Vin Diesel made a career on saying I
am right so who knows this guy this
meatball run can make a living on I am
meatball so meatball dub body double
back here yeah we're gonna get that
rumor started we're gonna see because we
think I really think think Liz
Harrington listens to this show when we
when we evaluate the Trump videos oh yes
every time we've given them critiques
they've changed it they've made yes they
make those tweaks that we're
recommending so I want to know Liz is
this really a meatball body double is
there a meatball we need to start a
conspiracy theory here
um a real one it's a it's true 100 dude
I mean look at this evidence look at
this evidence look at that dude the gate
that he has right there it looks pretty
does he have white boots on you can't
see his boots yeah we'll probably won't
see it because he's going to come closer
so right right well this this is um a
clip now this is from a different angle
than what the Trump campaign put out the
Trump campaign put out an angle that's
kind of back Beyond uh Jr there
but this is the angle right up in the
face of these people where you can hear
what this toxic sludge is saying now
listen to what he says about
the time that they should have right you
know that nice to see you thank you have
a good time you look so great
have fun everybody
have a good time and have fun everybody
what the he doesn't need to throw paper
towels to with these people hey
guys I know that your living situation
is probably for the foreseeable
future and you probably have to move and
you probably won't have enough money to
move because you'll be dealing with this
litigation lawsuit for I don't know how
many years but hey have a good day okay
I mean this is I can tell you so I uh in
the town in the town over from where I
lived in Chicago
there was a bunch of toxic waste that a
company had had well I guess they had
been pretty much dumped in this area
right you're saying that this isn't just
the first time toxic chemicals has been
dumped somewhere yeah yeah there wasn't
a train derailment though there was a
train nearby but it was not a trained
around it just over years this private
what you're saying but you're saying
yeah they okay yeah I dumped this
in an area
and what happened was it turns out that
oh those toxic chemicals I don't know
seep into the ground or something and
then they go into the dirt and the grass
in the water and they feed into other
things because hey everything is
connected underneath the surface right
circle of life I'm just saying I'm just
saying
so what ended up happening
was for I want to say several several
years they basically had this white
uh Dome over this park that had it they
had to go they had to dig deep deep deep
deep deep deep down right they had to
relocate people because they're like
look we need to dig underneath your
house we need to do all of this stuff
they dug way deep
dispose of that dirt that toxic dirt
and then rebuilt that area from the
ground up I mean below the ground up
really and then built a park on it and
then it's it's obviously much better now
but it was years the thing was just
trapped off you you drive past the
highway and you see this big white
umbrella Dome that was sealed off it
looked like you were like oh is there
like some sort of experiment going on
like the one with the movie remember the
Pauly Shore movie in the 90s biodome
yeah except I couldn't see into it
biodome was at least clear it was like a
huge Greenhouse wasn't it this one was a
big white tent that was sealed off and
it was like people in in hazmat suits
the only thing I remember most about
biodome other than polyshore is uh when
they went around and collected the
cigarette butts to take the filters to
filter the air you remember that part no
I don't remember yeah they used they
used cigarette butts you know they like
put them on a thing it's been so long
since I've seen that movie I just
recently started one I was started to
watch I didn't finish it but I started
watching uh Encino Man the other day
because it happened that's a good one
yeah
that's a good one um here here is uh
what does he say about the juices no
this is the water so it'll it'll set up
the whole context so it's uh it's the
guy it's the it's only 24 seconds long
we're gonna get the full context yeah
yeah this is Access Hollywood this is
Sylvester Stallone you said what's his
face that was on the axis Hollywood bus
that same guy
oh
um Billy Bush yeah yeah is that it the
little bushing it might get it right
yeah I think it's he's the guy that
Trump was like grabbing by the
he's like
kind of ruined his career I don't know
why
um yeah
so here's the old uh the old um
Sylvester stall now to give context here
Sylvester Stallone is not like some kind
of Hollywood liberal right he's not some
kind of lip tart from Hollywood like
he's kind of like um Bruce Willis yeah I
mean we're kind of Dwayne Johnson like
they consider themselves Republican
right right I mean he's he was recently
at Mar-A-Lago right well I mean yeah he
would hang out with with yeah but but I
mean uh and I don't know if you know
this speaking of Bruce Willis I don't
mean to get off topic here did you know
that guys get some sort of like he's got
a dementia yeah that's crazy he's got
some sort of rare it's really bad at
first at first when yeah not to go off
on a tangent when I first read about it
like I think a few months back he
basically announced that he was retiring
from and I'm sure at the time they knew
what it was but what they had announced
was he had some form of like
it was a
I forget the name of what it was but it
wasn't this Dimension it was something
else entirely which basically like it
was like something Aphasia I think is
what it was it was like really it was
well because he'd been in the hospital
several times they weren't sure what it
was but they just diagnosed it so we're
gonna get to this clip but first I want
to add Jimmy on Facebook he he reminded
me here on acino man wheezing the juices
in the juices
in the juices okay so here is Sylvester
Stallone asked if he wants to drink the
Trump water let's listen that's the
better water are you serious and guess
who the other water is whatever it is I
wouldn't wash my socks in this
ah now I can't wait to tell you what it
is what Trump ice
[Laughter]
I didn't know I love Donald I'm sorry
wash his socks in it
dude it is so good oh my God it's
amazing I gotta I gotta Play It Again
they're probably Gonna Knock us for
copyright but I don't give a that's
the better water are you serious and
guess who the other water is whatever it
is I wouldn't wash my socks
and now I can't wait to tell you what it
is what Trump ice
the whole crew
is just I don't know I'm sorry
oh
man oh that's the best clip
listen
breaks if we would have found that clip
in 2016 I don't even think that
would have been president
oh my God oh my God I cannot believe
I've never seen that clip oh man I came
across it last night and I was like this
is definitely going in my what was that
oh my God
so he called the Trump water Trump ice
then huh yeah yeah is that what's the
name I think that's what it is I mean
it's probably part I mean he did have an
ice company so I I guess it's part of
that same uh
me that's hilarious holy I'm
retweeting that I'm Gonna Save that
I'm I'm pulling it did you
get a copy of it I have I have the I
have the YouTube version of it so I'm
going to be don't worry everyone yeah
like a high quality age I mean it's not
it's I mean this is like 15 years ago
this 2007 so it wasn't like the highest
quality video that we were getting but I
can tell you that I have the highest
quality version
it's public
it will be making its way into
um hey Access Hollywood we would love to
do a deal where I could uh get a higher
quality if you've got it we would love
to holy that is oh my God man it
sounded like Johnny Knoxville was in
that room like that laugh
that was happening I was like like I got
a crazy too good this is too good I've
got a crazy cackle but there there's
someone in that room that just somebody
uh Ben Ben says why is Sly apologizing
to Trump so this is years ago this is
before he ran this is two thousand this
is during this is during the Celebrity
Apprentice yeah during when the
Celebrity Apprentice because The
Apprentice was good but then when they
started putting celebrities on they
learned that oh more people want to
watch people right exactly and then at
that point nobody knew all of the stuff
that we know now right and nobody or
some people were talking but it wasn't
mainstream and when you've got a guy on
TV and prime time you know on Thursday
nights or whatever it was on NBC
everyone knows him from that so
everyone's always like you're fired you
know everyone called it the Cobra or
whatever was like you fired uh
uh and that's what people knew of them
and he was he was a celebrity in that
way and so that's why well the other
thing too is is the reason why you
wouldn't want to apologize to him is
because
Sylvester Stallone knows how much of a
man child that guy is yeah like
how much of a baby he is and that he
would he would be relentless towards him
um yeah and also he's a republican so
right yes absolutely that holy that
is uh the greatest one of the greatest
clips and I I honestly believe that that
if that clip this is an Access Hollywood
clip if this would have been the Access
Hollywood clip other than the
grabbing oh my God he would have lost he
would have gotten tanked in 2016. I
don't I don't care if it would have
shown that Hillary Clinton was colluding
with Russia to sell classified
information the Martians I don't give a
that clip totally would have buried
him in 2016. anyways sorry and I'm done
since I knew we were bringing up the
water that was great mocking it's great
mocking play this clip it's great
mocking um I want to show you a clip
here
um speaking of high on the derailment of
that the right wing is riding around a
Pete bootage mayor Pete oh my God mayor
Pete Pete hello
here's the here's the one they're
spreading around I don't know who the
um oh yes yes oh it's this this
DC Drano
DC Dorado oh you aren't Drano my friend
um this direction right probably this is
a turning points USA they got a brand
attorney Point GSA now this is a cop or
is this a fake cop well I mean it might
be a Herschel Walker style cop but you
see this this is a this is an official
in the town and you're gonna see he's
talking here right he's he's having a
conversation with someone and you're
gonna see that someone walk into the
frame now you're gonna hear reporters
yelling
questions but this person stays focused
on the conversation that he's having
because it's probably pretty important
to I don't know like the protocol of the
cleanup and getting the town back in a
situation where it doesn't have toxic
sludge like Trump leaking around and
it's McDonald's yeah let's listen let's
listen to this clip okay why did it take
two and a half
presidents of this city for for the the
slow response to the government's slow
response you have any apology and of
course they're like oh he's running away
and he won't answer questions he's
actually in a conversation to fix the
problem that you are
bitching about that he's not fixing he's
I can also guarantee that woman is not
from that town she came in from some
other network and was like why are you
doing anything and it's like dude uh you
just got here but also if you did your
research like a good journalist or
reporter which you're not you would
realize that the problem actually
originated with Trump repealing the
regulation right oh we gotta roll back
the regulation we gotta deregulate we
gotta we gotta strip the government's
control of everything uh pretty sure if
we did that uh we would have child labor
again we would have unsafe work
conditions health conditions eating
conditions there's a reason why we have
government agencies to make sure that
people don't die or get sick
it's it's weird it's weird and this here
the right wing is freaking out over
mayor Pete doing his job in Ohio today
right yeah which which he's done a lot
of his job from I don't know Washington
and the people on the ground there have
been doing a lot of the work
um that the Department of Transportation
can do but the Department of
Transportation is only allowed so much
uh leeway into the cleanup the EPA and
FEMA are the ones who handle that so
yeah this idea that somehow this
guy is the reason why the cleanup's
taking a slow amount of time like look
the Department of Transportation
secretary
isn't in charge of toxic cleanup okay
he's more in charge of I don't know
making sure the trains are trying to be
safe
under regulations that I don't know
Democrats past and Republicans repeal
because lobbyists went and got them to
repeal him but here is this I don't know
who this scab is
Jason Howerton with probably the dumbest
take oh it's I've seen it's a real
estate right so Tony Tony just you know
for for my sake and the sake of the
audience sure why would somebody wear uh
a hard hat or protective glasses in a
situation like this oh I'm gonna show
you why I'm gonna show you okay so so
this this this little picture here that
he posted is way out of context and
here's why and here's what he says mayor
Pete literally looks like a
five-year-old playing dress-up not to
mention the picture we have of
Donald Trump in a fire truck you
remember that yeah the the semi was like
it's a semi that was in the in the in
the front lawn of the White House right
they brought it to him and helped him up
in his fat ass up so he could pull the
horn
um here Pete is now he's on the ground
at the site where the Train derailed
like this is on the ground and that's
the reason why he's wearing this get up
and the reason why he's wearing this get
up Jason you idiot let me show
let me show let me show Jason why he's
oh yeah yeah please let me show him why
he's wearing this let me see if I can
find it here
um let me see if I can let me see if I
can educate this idiot
do you see this is Mayor Pete right here
so this is Mayor please why are all
these other guys why are all these
working-class people dressed up like
five-year-olds huh why why are they all
dressed up why do they have safety
glasses on what have hard hats and
reflective vests it's almost like
there's regulation or something what to
keep them safe or something all right
that's weird Republicans nobody
would wear these foot and
libtard blueware helmets
oh that's hilarious and I would bet the
you if you look here even the
photographer the guy taking pictures
here yeah
maybe that's that might be that might be
a woman it might be I don't know the
person there let's say that they if
you're oh my pronounce dude
don't force them that this person here
and who is the photographer they also
have on the protective gear
um as they're just taking photographs
because they're in the disaster area you
can see like these are the tanker cars
that are turned over and mayor Pete is
standing there
the re with the rest of the cleanup crew
who are also in the same get up because
that's the regulation it's really
dumb again I mean though
people are bringing up a good point
which I also wonder about which is like
if this is you know we've got toxins
chemicals that are in the air now I
don't know how long of a period
in terms of like safe to breathe or
anything but you have you you know
obviously have protective hats and
protective you know in case you slip or
fall you don't want to crack
your skull open
um especially in an uneven unsafe area
but if it's in the air then you do have
to wonder like oh why aren't you guys
wearing masks well and and the answer to
that question is because it's probably
not in the air it's probably not in the
air they probably tested the air in that
area and it it for the toxic chemicals
that would be in the air that you would
need a respirator for and there are no
toxic chemicals in that area that you
would need a respirator and the reason
why is because there's regulations to
wear it uh oh here's another this must
be where this I see I see what happened
I see what happened here Gabe Sanchez
what was his name what the is his
name I don't know Jason
oh Jason hey Jason I've got a
five-year-old Howerton well they are
obsessed with five-year-olds for some
reason
um look where he got it from oh man oh
we're laughing oh at the Hodge
twins yeah so this dumb this is
this is one of the worst
stand-up I've ever seen okay so they're
comedians they're funny how they started
was their their bot they're like
bodybuilders on YouTube and that's and I
saw some of their stuff early on like
years ago like 2011. was it funny then
it wasn't it wasn't that it was funny it
was just two twins being like
bodybuilders being like this is how we
do which is what we do they never really
into politics then Trump got in and they
got into politics they also do stand up
and if you ever watch their stand-up
sets they're all on YouTube thinking
it's the funniest thing that
graced the Earth is it Doug it's
terrible there's both of them on stage
and they're just doing the same thing
that Roseanne Barr and uh uh any
of these other my pronouns or kiss my
ass like the same or something about the
vaccine or the pronoun or whatever it
might be it's dumb comedy that punches
down and it's just not funny
so here is here is the hodgets because
this has got to be where Jason got it
from Jason you copycat you
ass can you come up with an
original idea how dare you on the
internet yeah here's here's what here's
what the highest you and say mayor P out
out there in a hard hat safety glasses
and orange vest yeah with all the other
people
that are standing in the
wreckage the reason why Trump didn't
wear a hard hat and a reflective
reflective vest because he didn't go
near the records you dumbasses
yeah
ridiculous and I'm gonna give him one
for why not tell him their tweet sucks
that's not what I want I don't want to
do that no no it's not what I
want Elon God damn it Elon
oh your Tweet sucks okay let's see if we
can find one more thing we get a couple
more minutes here I think I had one more
clip I'd like to show unless you got
something that she just had to show
today that was uh that was that was
that's the lone Trump that was my that
was my little oh my God moment that is
the best oh man
I gotta show you this this doesn't have
anything to do with Ohio but I'm going
to show it anyways and I got some Nazi
videos here I could show God damn it we
just run out of time all the
time this is ridiculous there's a the
Buffalo shooter um there's a woman who
spoke at at uh his sentencing is this
really great video yeah there's another
video of some some Trump dude
yeah I've seen this video I know the
video is talking about some trumped-up
dude approaching uh interracial couple
on this street I don't D I'm I can't
believe these people aren't like yelling
anti-semitic and and going up to
people you're surprised that nobody that
it's taking their teeth in
uh yeah that's uh that's you know that's
a mystery to me how these people survive
well you know I think those people are
also like oh you're recording me so I'm
gonna oh I was smart about it listen
that would be worth the assault charge
yeah 100 I'd go to jail again I
mean I would like to see one of these
days
I would love to see the camera like
start and then it finishes but like and
it just like Cycles if there were meat
that camera wouldn't be recording
because that's the first thing I do
they'd give me on two charges destroying
property because I'd smash the
camera and then I'd kick in his teeth
yeah what I mean this is what listen you
are like oh well we can't do that listen
in World War II anti the real antifa if
they would have been so soft that they
weren't willing to punch in Nazi we
would we would be right now a lot
worse than we are
um speaking of Nazis listen to
this now this is I think this is
out of Alaska yeah this is the Alaska
legislative it's Alaska yeah yeah I'm
gonna this is another one where I'm like
I gotta do what was that on this this is
crazy okay so they're talking
about they're talking about like um
funding that goes towards
um child like it goes to the families
right there that lost a child
right right and and this is another one
of those moments where they have to
assess the value of someone's life right
kind of the same thing you're talking
about earlier but listen listen to the
value that and I'm sure I don't know who
this is can we sniff out who this the
the person that says this is uh
I almost bet I almost bet they're like a
rated from the right to life and
like oh they're pro-life I'm the most
pro-life there is and all
that lie all those lies but listen to
what he says about if a kid dies it's
representative David Eastman he's Alaska
GOP State Rep David Eastman says and
then doubles down to which we'll watch
in a second let's let's listen
um you know in the case where child
abuse is fatal it obviously it's not
good for the child but it's actually a
benefit to society because there aren't
needed for government services and
whatnot over the whole course of that
child's life what what what was that
like that's your that's your no no like
it's like I'm sorry it's like straight
from the beginning I'm sorry what was
that so so he's basically saying there
in the first uh 14 seconds
I have a development once we go through
this okay so so
um he says if you didn't hear it clearly
they're talking about fatal child abuse
fatal so in other words if someone's
abusing a child and they die because of
it he's like look yeah the child dies
but it's a it's a it's good thing right
it's a good thing because now we don't
have to I don't know
support this person he's like
look if the baby's dead or the child
dies then like we didn't have to pay for
the benefits or the services that they
would normally have to be rendered to
help that child recover right well and
if it was a fetus he'd have a totally
different oh yeah
ex murder I mean nary's
like murder I mean is it murder or is it
really like he's like is it benefiting
Society yeah he's like I'm gonna take
the utilitarian or like aspect here was
like uh what's the what's the greater
benefit of society less cost okay great
well he goes into that let's listen
through the chair can you say that again
to say a benefit for Society come again
um talking dollars now you've got uh 1.5
million dollar price tag here for uh
victims of fatal child abuse
um it gets argued periodically that it's
actually
um a cost savings because that child is
not going to need any of those
government services that they might
otherwise
um you know be entitled to receive and
and need based on you know growing up in
this type of environment
God damn I mean just holy you can't
find a better pro-lifer out there than
this guy can you oh man I save the
children right I mean am I right am I
right yeah stay right I'm kill him oh my
god well guess what there's been a
development yeah there was a
development as of today so this is the
news GOP Maga pro-life politician David
Eastman has been censured after
suggesting fatal child abuse could be
cost saving uh so you know in this whole
thing and then uh his colleagues were
like shut the up man
right don't say that quiet part out loud
dude if you want to say it to yourself
whatever right so right he says he's in
a room alone this was this was Monday
this came out right this was this was
the video was uh Monday it's yeah Monday
yeah
220 23 is the right so expert Witnesses
were testifying about the long-term harm
the child abuse has in the economy to
the workforce and the taxpayers when
children who face abuse and the adults
they grow up to be rely on the
government right because it's almost
like there's a long lasting effect that
would be emotionally physically damaging
and you know
we would want to take care of those
people because hey like this countrymen
right yeah or good Christians or however
you want to say like Thy Neighbor right
ease up on the good Christian stuff
you're going to continue anyways but
yeah so he goes talking dollars all this
anyway so we received a bunch
of backlash from Democrat counter
counterpart Andrew Gray who called the
comments offensive uh insulting and
unstamped on on uh
uh unsubstantiated uh adding to
determine the dignity undermine the
Dignity of the house
so he brought a motion they have
Republicans have dignity left
in Alaska even though really I mean
you'd be you'll be digging for a while
to find it I guess so I guess there is
gold in Alaska but uh
so Mr Gray brought a motion to censure
against Mr Eastman on Wednesday which
was voted through the Republican
majority legislator 35 to 1. can you
guess who voted no
it was probably one of them liberal left
we Maniacs yeah it was one of those
blue-haired antifa oh no I'm sorry
actually it looks like it was oh it was
Eastman himself it was Eastman himself
he said oh wait guys don't censor me no
no don't do that right
um so and yeah it holds no I mean what
he actually would he actually I mean
it's just a show for them to say
officially shut the up please yeah
it's just saying it's just saying
dissatisfaction on the record it's the
same thing when they do the whole voter
ID thing right they say these things in
private rooms that get recorded and then
they go out into the public and they say
different things right yeah and then you
know he just fouled up and he said the
the part that there's but he doubled he
doubled down and he defended himself by
saying this was all a
mischaracterization oh really yeah yeah
he went on so we're supposed to believe
that we didn't hear what we heard is
that no no Tony look look he he said it
was wrong to say he's here he was like
oh uh I don't support child abuse when
I've uh when I've staked my entire
political career arguing the opposite
he's like he's arguing child fatalities
he's like look it's good that they die
he's not supporting child abuse let me
let me be clear on this that's not what
I'm accusing him of here listen listen
to the first 14 seconds again I'm not
accusing him of wanting child abuse or
um you know in the case where child
abuse is fatal it obviously it's not
good for the child but it's actually a
benefit to society because there aren't
needed for government services and
whatnot over the whole course of that
child's life he he is saying if there's
child abuse in the case that there's
child abuse we want them to die yeah
he's not advocating childhood he's just
saying when a kid is being abused he
would much rather they I mean
what what he's what he's saying is he's
like look yeah the baby died okay but
with that being said look at all the
things that we could save money on but
here's the thing he also this isn't the
first time he was censured okay he was
also centered in 2017 for saying that
some alaskans try to get pregnant so and
I say in the quotes I'm not misquoting
so they can get a free trip to the city
to get an abortion
wait wait like a vacation yeah like he's
like what he's arguing in 2017 is he
said some alaskans go through the
process of getting pregnant so they can
get a free trip to the city
to get an abortion I put the quotes
because that's what that's him quote
that's him quotes wait actually him
quotes this this makes about as much
sense as La is is let the children die
when they're being abused yeah I mean
there's no real logic to it but you want
to know what else happened what in 2017
when he said that he became now and he's
still the only one but he definitely has
this on his record he's the first
politician in State history to receive
Accenture now he's the only first and
only politician to have two two twofer
he's the only twofer in Alaska wait
that's weird 2017 2017 that's the same
year that Trump talks about rolling back
the regulations on the trains you don't
you know what else probably is a thing
that happened to you I bet I would
almost bet since this guy got censured
back in 2017 that he was re-elected in
between the time that he got censored
the first time and the time he got
censored this time is that am I right
insane let's look him up I would almost
imagine I would almost imagine that
their house their house in Alaska does
election every two years that's what I
would imagine I mean I'm just guessing I
don't know for sure but
uh I would almost bet that I would
almost bet that he's been elected maybe
not just once but twice since he said
that he assumed office in on January 17
2017 so right out of the gate he really
right he's an I mean he's a I
mean you think George Santos is an
God damn this guy wow okay oh
I'm now on his his Wikipedia okay so
Eastman was selected in April 2020 uh
April 2012 by Republicans in the house
district 13 as his first choice to fill
the Alaska house seat vacant by the
death of Representative Carl Gatto uh he
was selected as an Abraham Lincoln
fellow by the Claremont Institute in
2020 he was removed from his position on
the Ethics Committee after it was found
that he violated the state ethics law in
2017 by disclosing a confidential
information
he disclosed confidential information so
he was removed and despite several wait
he was on he was on the committee and
they had to remove him they didn't
remove him from from his position
because he created ethics about he was
on the empty this guy was on the Ethics
Committee he was on the Ethics Committee
removed from his position on the Ethics
Committee after he was found to be
violated the state ethics law these
so he was on the Ethics
Committee and he violated the state
ethics law in 2018 by disclosing
confidential information and despite
several attempts to disqualify him from
eligibility for elected office on August
16 2022 Eastman received
52.06 percent of the vote in the ring
Choice Open primary election for the
27th Alaska house district by
oh man was Tony right Tony's always
Eastman's new District yeah oh this was
his new District after Alaska
redistricting yeah because they did a
lot of redistricting and they did the
rank choice because that's what boxed
Sarah Palin out right yeah yeah but they
they were so disgusted by say our
payment but not this guy come on I'll
ask you can do better than this Eastman
oh wow man this whole thing is
crazy he was an activist for the Tea
Party Movement he opposed the
recognition of Black History Month
holy he's also a lifetime member oh
my God check this out he's a lifetime
member of The Oath Keepers no he's
an insurrectionist too he's a seditious
piece of that's holy yeah uh
yeah there's talk of like involvements
slept on his counsel when he'd visit
Alaska I don't know
this is crazy anyway I didn't know oh
man oh yeah this is definitely gonna be
an uh what was that oh boy well that's
great well I want to do one more thing
before we get announcements I got one
more video yeah I gotta play this is
like the funniest video I've seen all
day let's watch it that's the better
water are you serious and guess who the
other water is whatever it is I wouldn't
wash my socks it is
what Trump uh
I'm sorry
oh my God I'm gonna I'm gonna put that
on repeat if you feel sad if you feel
depressed if you're lonely out there uh
if you're even if you're suicidal call
the hotline but if you can watch this
video Until the meantime because it will
pep your spirit I wouldn't wash my socks
in it
do you know how bad water has to be to
not wash socks in it still best
Sylvester Stallone socks of all socks
this is Rocky this is a guy running
around in a sweat suit sweaty nasty
socks it's like anything anything and
it's like the big ass tube socks too
it's yeah the smallest yeah yeah oh dude
they're gross and he's like no I
wouldn't even use that for it Jesus
Christ so yeah he's like look I got
standards guys I'm not saying that
they're high standards but I got a
little bit of standards and they
definitely don't meet this sock
washing standards are not met so you
gotta what was that coming up with this
in it
um
go to patreon.com I am Gabe Sanchez uh
to check out what was that the patreon
that supports that piece of material
um but tell them tell them what you got
coming yeah so I am uh I'm filming I
just finished writing the George Santos
uh interview that he did with Pierce
Morgan uh I've and I've got that one so
I'm hoping to finish that one it'll go
up tomorrow
um I've got another one that's going to
be about Lauren bobert trying to act
smarter than uh Rachel Maddow gets owned
the train derailment situation uh I'm
going to talk about the another one I
got is the GOP education plan this whole
uh Eastman uh GOP Alaska representative
is another one I also just saw that Ben
Shapiro was I mean there's so many
things it takes so much time to make the
graphics and write the write the punch
the jokes and everything that's going on
but
um I just saw that Ben Shapiro was also
on Piers Morgan and there was the topic
of what is a woman so I might have to do
one on that I don't know we'll see but
it just takes a lot of time you know go
check go check Gabe's patreon out for
what was that because it does take time
and time is money so if you can support
him over there he's got some extras over
there and why you're on patreon you can
check my page out too patreon.com
Michaels you can follow all those links
down in the description below on YouTube
while you're on YouTube don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday we are here Live on
YouTube for two full hours today two
hours 15 minutes oh my God
keep going long get these clips you can
download every single episode for free
absolutely free it doesn't cost you a
goddamn thing Apple Spotify Google it's
um it's good too it's it's not like
Trump water you would know I mean you
you would watch a delicate with this you
could actually have a sip and not feel
like you're gonna die you know right you
can ingest it and be like oh this isn't
bleach this is great this is water this
is good stuff it's not poison
um if you want some poison tweets though
you might go to Antonio Michael's pod
follow us there and we tweet I tweet out
some crazy just go follow me too at
the Tony Michaels Gabe always is
tweeting so go follow him at I am Gabe
Sanchez follow us on Facebook you can
also go watch us live on the up wires
YouTube channel go to upwire.com if you
don't have twitch but you have an Amazon
Prime account remember one way you can
support the show absolutely free if you
have an Amazon Prime account and you
don't have twitch yet Go download the
App log in to your amp with your Amazon
Prime account on Twitch you get one free
Subs description every month with your
Prime account you could give it to us
and then help support the show doesn't
cost you a single nickel if you're not
giving that subscription away already
also how you can support the show is go
to
store.thetonymichaels.com check out all
our merch there we got some surface up
going on over there so go to
store.dtonymichaels.com where over time
tomorrow we'll be back with bone into
the week it's Friday yeah a lot of
boneheads this week oh a lot of them so
be watching be watching for that
bonehead of the week poll you can you
can go to the community tab on YouTube
that thing go to the community tab on
YouTube you can vote there you can vote
on Twitter as well at Tony Michaels pod
be looking for that bonehead of the week
poll I'm sure someone will hold us
accountable make sure we get that up
sometime in the evening they always do
everybody
same time same place tomorrow serve some
you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
em
foreign
[Music]